again draymond green with that one and  bazemore lost it  take advantage of it brandon ingram  pulled the chair out on him  lonzo in the corner he's available ties  it up  got it even at 50. i tell you what he's  shooting that thing today  y'all can say whatever y'all want to  about that young man he believes in  himself  seven or nothing runs for the pals he  believes in his skill set well how about  lonzo now four or five from beyond the  arc  right believe in yourself it don't make  a difference what people say about you  you know the time the work the energy  and effort that you don't put into your  game  let's watch it pay off keep shooting  that thing so